might be a little longer than that
second toe
Arch is great you think people are so
weird now we're not weird bro we made us
humans yeah
animal with feet
a hole hold on there we go the trailer
and you're talking about the feet
hold on now hold on now let's let that
there you go
I mean
still break it down let's see the arch
right there look at the arch well done
guys stop
okay I came
[Laughter]
here let's go here's the reason okay let
me just do a little bit I'm like the
length is it the length oh my God I'm
Kenny all right ready so this is crazy
we're doing this right now yo you're
crazy all due respect this is Barbie
what's that so doing right yeah it does
seem it does seem a bit long this one I
think is coming longer than that one but
the nails and everything you know who
else got that is Kourtney Kardashian
third toe longest see I'm gonna be
honest with you I'm gonna say something
that nobody has said right there I think
that's a foot double I think it's a I
think that's a foot double
I think that's a foot though I'll say it
but they're gonna get a foot double and
then not pick a good foot so they don't
know you'd be shocked how much people
don't know you would be you'd be shy you
should put a human hand there you
probably [__] it yeah I don't care we're
involved bro we're in the future
that argument the logic foolproof
Flawless you stop a [__] fish with
feet or some [__] he's all the way in
the Jurassic period you're not even in
the future that's another thing I like
when [__] smell like fish no don't do
that no no
yo where did we evolve from the ocean
the ocean that [__] was fishy back in
the day bro it was mostly fish It's Just
Fish it was fish if we can fall from the
ocean say again did we evolve from the
ocean we started in the ocean
Started From The Bottom
we did no we started I mean according to
these uh you know atheist bum biologists
yeah I don't know [__] that you
Christian knows but you're Christian now
yeah I am Christian I watched my Sunday
service shout out to Renaissance that
was crazy though back in the day like
everyone was animals and then it just
went from bestiality to not that like
there was one guy that was still doing
bestiality they're like yo we're off
that we're just doing Homo Sapien like
yo is he making my argument to me is he
actually doing back in the day is he
actually doing it as old did he they
just [__] make the exact argument
you're on still like oh bestiality is
kind of cool that's basically what you
said this guy's a goofy bro
I didn't see it
and flip it I'm saying this is what
Christians do you have the Jewish
version and they're like oh no this is
better exactly no no
we know that third toe is is on some
Gumby [__] so we need a foot Checker
let's see let's see this website you're
not gonna get it oh oh no hold on now
oh let me extendo
can I say one thing real quick yeah I
know why they did that thing I thought
that they did that scene just for the
foot fetish people like myself which is
not a foot Fest just for the humans that
created Evolution like myself
that's what I thought okay that's how
Barbie stands right
it makes sense
caveman you know what I mean I really do
like feet yeah what that's crazy
what are you thinking about the doll
[Laughter]
s
[Music]
that's a foot double bro I think we got
a foot double we got it we got it we
called him out we caught him caught him
red-handed caught him red-handed she
don't got no beach pics I think she's
elusive bro
this is Moby Dick dude we're just all
right yo she'll never take pics on the
beach
this [__] don't like to swim it's tough
because the second and third there
seemed like same so is that she's a
great foot she's a great foot she's like
a great foot what's your take on a
little foot tattoo
usually it's for fat girls because
that's the only skin that doesn't
stretch on their whole bodies but that
one's a small and tasteful I don't like
a tattoo also also there's more turnover
on the epidermis on your foot so it gets
blurry it's not good bad bad bad yeah
what tattoos what what is that something
back in the day it's an anchor
how do you know that uh because I have
eyeballs no you can't really see it I
zoomed in it's an anchor yeah you just
can't see she's Australian see come on
dub don't do that
yo it's a foot double I think it's a
foot double it's a guaranteed foot
double it's 100 but why would she fit
double to a worse foot because they
don't know
I don't care if it's a better photo or
Worse foot I don't need to be
objectified further you don't want to be
bothered
it should only be bothered it's like you
don't need me for this part of the shoe
I'm good but if she was a pure she would
do it yeah she'd be like yo he
understood what we understand so that
third so that's wild
that third toe is erect
that third show is Stefan you know in
the cartoon when they Hammer their thumb
and it goes crazy yeah but still a
beautiful foot like I you know I want to
objectify you possibly
yeah hilarious but I am a truest about
this this [__] yeah I mean you're
welcome you think that's a ballerina or
like someone's on a
sloped green screen nope
it's not even close not a ballerina at
all
I mean if we really want to get into
this we can get into I come from a
dancing family like if we really want to
get into this I can get it get into it a
ballerina would never have a foot that
beautiful the ballerina's foot is
absolutely destroyed from years of being
on point
never would be a ballerina I'm sorry
that's what I'm talking about give me
that one right there
nope you're wrong wait which one no back
to the theater movie theater right there
dirt foot yeah I wish it wasn't dirty
but I think that's part of the character
honestly it's a foot double no it might
be it might be it might be her it's a
foot double dude you know why because if
it was actually Margot Robbie's foot
data just zoomed out and showed Margot
Robbie
because they know what I mean the people
what they want
um
okay good point good point